all right guys
bang bang we got sean here thank you so
much for doing this let's do it all
right we're in miami you're here for a
couple of days
let's just start with what do you think
about miami miami's sweet i mean uh i'm
sweating
24 7. so that's not so great i i don't
know if you've seen these but hold on
where's the
i don't know if the cameras can see
these but i went into a mall
i went into a mall right when i got to
miami if you're listening to the audio i
just showed my
fire short cheetah pants um
and i just said i need the most miami
thing you got and she showed me
something nice
and i was like no no i need too much i
want to look like you know the grand
theft auto cover
and she's like oh okay come over here
and she gave me these things because we
were doing a live show
and i wanted to look goofy but miami's
cool the energy's great
i mean it's it feels like when you go
from a corporate office
to a startup office and you're like oh
y'all got snacks like oh
okay like this guy's just sleeping here
it's like yeah he sleeps there he
you don't have to wear a student tonight
no you don't like do you wear jeans yeah
like that's cool there's a dog in the
office
and so that's what miami feels like
coming from san francisco and i hate
that because i'm
i'm still living in san francisco but
it's truly what it feels like it's like
that may be your
description i've heard of miami so far
yeah of like miami is the startup office
and san francisco is
you know what i mean right like where
you go from one to the other yeah and
but i also think um
there's other elements of truth to that
which is uh i continue to tell people
that
folks who have moved to miami uh one
they're serious there's nobody who like
is here because they want to go to like
the yc party right or like get into the
latest like product hunt party
it's like no they're here and they have
a company they invest like they're
they're
uh real movers in in terms of what
they're doing the second thing is they
have a chip on their shoulder which is
exactly what a starter pack is right
of just like okay cool you guys think
this is hype like we're going to make it
underdog story yeah yeah and then the
third one of my favorite uh is somebody
said to me
miami will be successful if keith rowe
boy moved there and doesn't try to
retire
like he moved to retire he moved to work
and obviously he's working right so like
if you move to work then like miami
would be successful because there is
some gravity in florida to just like you
know get you to just chill so
you know if you can resist the gravity
it's going to be great i don't you know
they're
uh the startup scene here i feel like
there is the great filter
because for to pick up and move is no
joke right
even if you're you know 23 years old and
you're young and you're single
you still got to move like it's still
like the final place to find a place
it's a decision
it's like not an easy thing to just sort
of it's not a it's not an easy um
two-way door it's more of a one-way door
and so
i think that filter is a awesome thing
if you can get enough momentum and like
you know through whatever forces you
know whether it's the mayor or keith or
boy or
a bunch of other people enough momentum
got started but the
casuals weren't gonna come because it's
too inconvenient to just pick up and
move your whole life
so the only people who came are people
who are like all right i'm down for the
cause
you know like i'm i'll do this and so uh
was it a hard decision for you you moved
here
no uh i mean look it was basically
i came i on a vacation right uh
for a couple days liked it came back
like a week later
uh this time i was like wait maybe we
should actually do this and then
uh we were here within like four weeks
and we just said let's figure it out and
are you going to this bitcoin
bitcoin conference is going on right now
yeah i haven't been to it yet have you
do you attend any of it i went it's
absolute madness so and had you gone
before to the previous years so tell me
what's the progression think of uh in
prior years it was
low single digit thousands it's now 10
to 20 000 people
like big steps some things get ruined
when it gets to that like right
sometimes things lose the the initial
core group and
i forget too big too commercial is that
what's happening or no i forget who said
it last night but somebody was like this
will be bigger than south by southwest
by next year
and i think that's really bad right and
it has a lot of the same
feelings of kind of early south by
southwest of like if you didn't go you
kind of have a little bit of fomo
uh and you knew there was a lot of value
but like the fringe was a little bit of
[ __ ] right right um
and then like kind of over time it
became more commercialized whatever uh
i think that we're not quite there yet
but like you can feel
you know it's getting closer and closer
to that just law of large numbers
um but the quality of the actual like
content and the speakers and all this
you got to remember that
if bitcoin i think it's at 180 000
bitcoin price
50 of the force 400 is going to come
from the bitcoin and crypto industry at
180k
about right i mean it's hard to tell
exactly whatever
but like about 50 of the 400 rich people
in the world are going to come from one
industry
maybe later this year right right that's
going to be a very different group of
wealthy people
right like they're different there's a
different sort of folk right well
they're they're anti-establishment by
nature right
right some are deep technologists some
are deep like anarchists
and then some are mad men who just like
went all in
and then some actually are just very
intelligent macro economic right you
know thinkers or investors or whatever
so like you get like this
very different group of people but i do
think it's interesting when
uh you have that kind of wealth transfer
um
because also you have to remember that
who front ran the whole thing it's all
retail yeah
right and so it's like this wasn't a
thing where oh rich people are just
going to get richer because that's
usually what happens right you get the
concentration wealth and the quality gap
instead what we have this is none of
these people on the list before
right yeah so it's like you're it
literally is a
wealth transfer in that sense right this
wasn't old and rich get richer this was
the smart brave and young crazy you know
got richer you know for the most part
and so i think that that's that's
interesting that's what that has all
these different knock-on effects
okay so what do they like to buy maybe
they're not as into cars maybe they'll
spend
you know a million dollars on an nft and
it'll feel very natural to them or
you know so on and so on different types
of philanthropy so i think it's it's
very
i love the grand experiment of what if
we took the snow globe
and we just shake it up and now now some
some different things are happening and
we're going to see like the second order
third order
consequences of a whole new class of
wealthy people
i also think there's uh much more
long-term thinking
that goes on here just given the nature
of the asset right when you live in a
world where the underlying currency gets
depreciated
it's obviously financial incentives for
short-term uh when you have this
idea of bitcoin and kind of an
appreciating purchasing power
um if it works right which still isn't
if but but
most likely will um it just makes you
think much more long term and so like
how does that change what people do with
their wealth how does that change
philanthropy how does that change the
way they build companies like
it's very interesting dynamic that i
don't think we've seen yet and so
you know so far so good but it's
different right you know the other thing
i was thinking about with when you were
talking about the bitcoin conference
so i went here and like you could see
the energy there's a lot of people here
a lot of excitement
crazy billboards right now for different
things somebody was walking by and they
go oh that's that scammy guy from
youtube there's
some guy has like a a bus a bus ad he's
doing
and he's like you know i know exactly
who so i thought that was and then
somebody else i think your guy jordy was
saying he's like i was backstage at the
thing he's like
dude this is like my youtube suggested
feed walking around you know talking to
each other which i think is just cool in
general
but i have these ideas of like i think
that somebody so you said this is gonna
be bigger than south by southwest
bigger and uh there's a couple different
ways you can measure that right uh i
don't know how
big south by southwest is in terms of uh
attendees right but i think bigger from
like an influence
right relevance yeah exactly so so let's
just say i don't know ben you could
check on this but the south by southwest
might be like 70 000 80 000 people i
don't know
ballpark um i agree with you it's gonna
get bigger
i also think there's an opportunity
right now i
i will i want these to exist but i'm not
going to like organize these because
i hate events i would never do events
but i've always thought
there's a big opportunity to do novel
events so
um my investor had in my previous
company he had like this huge
like land and wine country in sonoma and
i was trying to convince them to do
north by northwest
and just do the like some people are
tired south by southwest too saturated
cool let's just restart with north by
northwest let's just do a new one
um or like i think if the crypto
community decided to like
fork burning man and just created like a
new version of burning man and instead
of you know
burning the man at the end it's like you
know something else fiat you know
i think that there's a lot of energy
around getting this group of people
together that share some beliefs
but in these contexts that are you know
these like you know escapes right it's
like burning man's like a version of
vegas or mardi gras where it's like
a place where you can go and it's normal
to behave totally differently than you
can do day to day
i think society likes that and i think
crypto is just like a very unique
uh it is a subculture and i'm surprised
that there are not more
interesting events like a conference is
a conference right like you can go and
you can sit on the panel but like we
we're all on youtube every day we all
watch the same guys you know like
if i wanted michael saylor to tell me
that you know bitcoin is a bank in
cyberspace like i could just
click that on youtube i don't need to go
to a panel to see that but if somebody
created like a
more of a life experience like burning
man i think that would do well so
uh without saying too much there are
things like that
they're super private i see so people
i'm just not invited
well and even most people in like the
crypto bitcoin world aren't invited
and uh the types of people that go are
very interesting right like
i know of one or two where some of them
are like the largest hedge fund managers
in the world
mixed with like you know some bitcoin
billionaire who literally 10 years ago
like had no money right right and you
start to like
look at this and it's like a very
interesting dynamic uh the other thing
that's
uh very unique about this space is
uh let's say that you and i go to a uh
wall street
event i pretty much know who's rich in
the room yes
and i probably know how much money they
have right right because
either the media has covered it or you
know who started what firms you know how
much aum they have
like you can do back of the navigate
math and and uh whatever
tech started to kind of break that up a
little bit because like the kid in the
hoodie
could have built a company that was
worthless can't underestimate anyone
yeah
like but still we know who the founder
of
uh facebook was we knew who the founder
of twitter was like there was still this
like hierarchical structure to it a
little bit but
if you weren't in the industry then you
kind of had to be careful
bitcoin crypto like anybody yes like
literally you could walk up to somebody
and you don't know if they have a couple
hundred million dollars of bitcoin
or like they just bought their first
bitcoin right and the smart people don't
tell you
right and so like there's this uh very
um empowering aspect to that because now
all of a sudden it's not about
who the person is in terms of like the
wealth that they have it really is
more of who has the best ideas right
right who's the most interesting and and
so
uh that'll probably go away which is
unfortunate because over time people
just kind of
figure it out uh but right now like i
think that's one of the most enjoyable
parts it's like
you just don't know right yeah and you
can't uh because
it didn't take a lot of money to get
there early what is what get what really
gets you there for the most part and so
anybody could have been early and there
is a sort of a layer of
anonymity around it that if you said if
you're smart you choose to do
i have a theory i don't even know how we
would go and figure this out
but uh majority of the people who are in
what i call wave one or phase one
uh they actually are not that wealthy
right because they bought
at you know two dollars it went to ten
i'm a genius yeah sell it
right like five extra money you fools
think this is actually going to work
there are a couple of folks who uh have
helped the entire time and done very
very well but for the most part
i think most people kind of along the
way just naturally would sell
uh the phase two is actually where i
think most of the wealth what are you
calling phase two like what price points
are you thinking there is that like
a hundred or a thousand what are you
thinking no i think that there's like
we're now in
phase four so like think of it as like
you know i don't know
sub 100 like then there's kind of like a
hundred dollars then a thousand and
maybe like now like 10 000 plus right
uh and so like around the you know maybe
a hundred to a thousand dollar price
point those are people who are coming in
with much more money
they were much more sophisticated for
the most part uh there's more
infrastructure in place
uh the ability to secure the assets like
it was just a little bit
different phase three was when like okay
now like
mega wealthy et cetera coming in but
that phase two i think is where you get
most of like the crypto billionaires and
i think that's right yeah i think that's
right
um all right we weren't supposed to talk
about any of this yeah uh let's talk
about what we're actually here to talk
about
so there's this rise of individuals and
we see individuals versus like
corporations organizations
across society uh everything um from
the media to investing to building
companies
all this stuff i want to talk about this
like confluence or combination
of uh what you and i are interested in
which is basically like
i'm interested in technology and
business i'm interested in investing and
i'm interested in
content right and when i put all these
things together it falls under this like
solo capitalist solopreneur um
uh idea i don't know if there's a term
yet that like
okay this is the one we're going with
right but like when you say those two
terms i think people know we're talking
about yes
i think people know some people know
what that means now and
what i think is going to be interesting
is the more people who do this the more
i guess like of a of a light is going to
be so this could be more innovation
people could be trying different things
the second thing is people are going to
start to realize they're going to see it
for what it is for example
it's called solo capitalist you have
four people here i got
ben came with me like we we have small
teams actually with us so it's not
nobody who says their solo is ever truly
solo very rarely we
mean somebody's truly solo but it is
this mindset of like
do i want to go start a startup do i
want to start a company
or am i the company right or can we just
like sort of have like
this one can we like either work
we start with we start with investing
and then we go into either building and
making content or we start with content
and then we go
and we say oh great we have this
audience maybe we should start
leveraging that
through building businesses and
launching products or
um investing in businesses and that
seems to work and i think that that's
how do you think about it like is it
content first or is it
the investing slash like products first
so i think it's uh
neither i think there's a so i drew this
like diagram
and in the center of it is basically the
like what i call the secret sauce
it's basically what is it that you bring
to the table that you know your unique
combination of like
prior experience knowledge passion and
interest whatever
so for you it's like you worked at tech
companies you worked at facebook or
snap whatever and so you have the like
tech
growth kind of like knowledge network
effect businesses uh
knowledge and then you had an interest
or a passion
in let's say crypto and then you had a
skill at being able to you had the gift
of gab right so you can actually like
create [ __ ] with the best yeah
exactly professional bullshitter
okay great so um so you know there's a
lot of people who work in tech not all
of them are passionate about crypto and
we're like brave enough to sort of like
be out there in the forefront before it
was cool
and then also like of those how many can
actually create consistently
entertaining content
very few so you end up competing in
these like n of one
like arenas where it's like well there's
not that many people i'm even competing
with usually
uh like single digits of serious players
so that's the secret sauce then from
there you just pick one of the
directions to start i like to start with
content because i think that
uh assets are the most valuable thing i
think audience is a great asset
so you know it is like we launched a
course
uh a few days ago i tweeted out one
tweet that said
hey i'm gonna do this course on power
writing i was basically just like you
know like
some people write to express themselves
some people write to impress other
people
i write to get a result like if i write
something i'm trying to go viral i'm
trying to get somebody to reply to my
email
i'm trying to get somebody to buy on my
website and so like that's why i write i
want to write to get a result
and i've learned a bunch of tips on that
one tweet has generated a course that's
gonna do
over six you know he's gonna do six
figures off of one tweet
how do you do that well because i have
this audience asset which is like
a group of people who like listen and
trust me and so i think that that's the
for me i'm like that's the asset you
want to keep pumping into through
content usually so basically you use
that for everything else you've
basically gone out and you found the
customers
right and i put customers kind of an air
quote like the audience
is subscribing to you to your philosophy
to your ideas
uh and they want more sean and then what
you're doing is you're figuring out
okay what are all the different ways
that i can interact with them from
building
software products to a course to hey
just come meet up and like let's hang
out and have fun
whatever the the interactions are the
touch points
having the audience is actually the kind
of key first step to be able to do
everything else so like in physics you
have potential energy
and you turn that into kinetic energy
right a ball at the top of the ramp
it's only potential energy zero kinetic
as soon as it starts to roll
all that potential becomes kinetic
that's how i think about
audience audience is the potential
energy and
one thing i would just kind of my edit
to what you just said is
it's not that they want more sean they
want more of something in their life so
like let's say
they want more money in their life and
so they might decide to inve co-invest
with me
through my rolling fund into startups or
they want more
they want to be a better writer they
want to themselves go viral or get more
results or you know like
have emails that people actually reply
to cold emails or whatnot
um okay well so they want certain
results they want more certainty on what
to do in life
so that's why they listen to you know
the podcast try to get some ideas or get
some advice on things
so i think people have these the
customer has some needs
and i just i go and i pre build a
trust and rapport with that audience by
just giving them free value
free content and if they like it they
stick around and then
when they have a need i basically build
a product for it so it's like
i built a chrome extension that's just
like a to-do list of one thing because
that's how i run my dav one one big
thing i do every day
and so i built a chrome extension for
that and that helps people who wanted
that
i'll do a paid newsletter i'll do a
rolling front i'll do you know so i'll
create all these different products
to try to see can i can i give the same
batch of customers
like more value all right let's talk
about the content first and then we'll
get into some of the other stuff
from a content perspective how do you
think about the different platforms like
where you focus your time
versus uh not even spending a single
second right there's so many platforms
to choose from
where do you focus and like why did you
choose those platforms
so i learned this from you actually uh i
asked you i think early or
the first podcast we did i was like so
how did you
how did you build this pomp character
you know like how'd you build this guy
and uh and you were you were like well
like you know
obviously it organically evolved but
like i did have a few things that i
identified you were like twitter
i'm gonna go for twitter because twitter
has this retweet button so if i want my
message to spread
like this platform has that as a spread
button like built in
and uh so that's pretty powerful so let
me like let me use that to like grow the
top
off the top of the funnel and then you
know
so and it's like well should i do 10
platforms at once like well no probably
not you should probably like
build one platform first focus and then
transfer so i basically just did the
same thing
so when i think after after that podcast
i was like all right i'm gonna build my
twitter up i think i might have had
20 000 followers at that time what do
you have today
140 150 okay so i added like a hundred
thousand dollars and four six seven
actually
and so it was like in the next three
four months i'm gonna add a hundred
thousand followers and i did it and so
so i was like let me go if i go all in
on this can i get to that top of the
funnel
so that's the first thing i did and that
helped grow the podcast so then i was
able to like
transfer that that energy and say all
right now i'm gonna build this podcast
up
and so the podcast is i think better
because
it's a much more trusted relationship uh
you know when i sold my last company i
thought about all right
what's like do i just do this again like
i got off the roller coaster all right
do i just like wait in line and
go again like that seems weird or do i
like is are there other rides at this
amusement park
that seemed fun and the one i thought
seemed the most fun was
i don't know about you but like i had
always had these books
and podcasts that like had really like
shifted me like shaped my life like
really shaped my thinking or like just
kept me entertained when i was bored
every day on my commute or whatever
and so i thought man if i could just be
in you know
in a million people's ears every morning
that would be
something and um and so i just made that
my goal how do i get into a million
people's ears every morning
and then like you know started with zero
and then it's built up and so like now
i think we're at like we'll do like 650
000 downloads a month right now and so
it's like
and it's growing like 30 30 30 to 40 a
month
and so um so i think we'll get to you
know like
it'll take time but like i think it'll
get to that million people a day that
that listen that's ambitious but like
give me give me five ten years and i'll
get there there's something very
intimate
uh and i don't have it fully fleshed out
yet but like somebody puts headphones in
and you're speaking into their ear like
that is a very intimate
experience right if you if i was to like
walk up to you if you whispered in my
ears
yeah like that'd be weird right like
you'd be like dude stay away from me
i like you but we're not like that yeah
and so like if you think about
uh kind of what else does that happen
right somebody's telling you a secret
uh it's at a bar or a club where it's
loud it's very in like
it it's this unique thing the next best
thing to kissing yeah
right like i mean what's this what's the
only thing more intimate to that right
just give anyone on the list it's
society from a society's perspective
this is like acceptable right
you can do it to a million people a day
no exactly no one gets weirded out
uh and then so i i do think that there's
this element of
podcast that uh one is passive listening
right in terms i don't have to do
anything
uh two is um i don't want to say who it
is but uh somebody told me that
clubhouse for them uh just in terms of
audio so it wasn't necessarily a
clubhouse specific but but audio
uh was really helpful for them because
they just had a child and so they were
taking care of the child
it was a hands-free experience right and
so they were able to just kind of listen
participate whatever
so i do think podcast is a very unique
thing uh what's hard about podcast
is uh you can definitely convince
people hey uh there's a product or go
here or do whatever
but the actual action of doing it's very
different than anywhere else on the
internet
on twitter you put out a tweet i can
just click the link right i'm already in
the mode of
i got my hands on a keyboard right like
okay i can go ahead and tap
podcasts i have to stop listening right
i have to go somewhere and take an
action it's a
much much different uh experience and
also the
uh the the action of listening is
different
right in terms of youtube feeds me the
video right it says hey recommendation
uh if you send me an email you feed it
into my inbox
with a podcast i basically have to go to
your podcast if you have to click play
and that intentional action is a much
higher bar i think to get people coming
back over and over and over again than
any other platform
right it's not easy to share if i share
with somebody a podcast it's like
hey man got got an hour to listen like
it's kind of you know like that's a
what kind of friend am i and so i think
that's why podcasts are really really
hard to grow
but it's also quite defensible when you
have a big audience it's good
if i could go back i would have skipped
podcasting gone straight to youtube
um i think you're more youtube centric
um and email centric i think than
than we are but i would say youtube is
better because
uh video is even more trust building
than audio you get the audio anyways
and you get their face and people's
faces is like you know the next kind of
more
most familiar thing that you get used to
so i think i think video would have been
better and i think a lot of people use
youtube sometimes
like sometimes i'm watching sometimes
it's in the background sometimes it's on
the screen second screen that i'm not
paying attention to
and so um i was talking to um
i was talking to emmett who's the ceo of
twitch where they acquired my company
and
um he we were like kind of like writing
the like annual strategy letter or so
i was reading the annual strategy kind
of like memo in the company and one
thing i wrote was like
i just left a note i said i think
the data shows that a lot of people used
to which is like a second screen
experience and at first team was like oh
no is this bad if we're not the four
if we're not the tab that they're
staring at the whole time it's like well
no they actually wanted to like pop in
pop out listen in the background while
they're doing something else like
uh it's like why friends or the office
is so popular on netflix is because it's
it's mindless i don't even have to watch
it i'm so i've already seen it it's
already felt so familiar
that i can just have it on i can have
noise in the house while i'm doing other
things
and so i said every investor cares about
tam the total addressable market
i said the tam of partial attention
is bigger than the tam of full attention
and actually like there's a whole group
of products that should be going after
partial attention because
it's actually a bigger market there's
more available size and there's like
less good options for it um and i think
clubhouse one of the reasons it rose to
its initial hype was um it was a partial
attention
social network you didn't have to like
be looking at the screen and using your
hand to like navigate
you could just be doing other things
rich from lightspeed uh which
he's a tmt analyst and basically he
spends all day thinking about this stuff
uh he once told me this and i think it's
probably the best way to think about all
of the different uh platforms
he said most people think of like the
streaming wars right it's uh
spotify versus itunes versus whoever
uh they think of uh the video platforms
it's netflix versus hulu versus you know
whatever
um they think of the social networks
it's facebook uh and instagram versus
twitter
um and when you start to think about
that like okay those are like
vertically uh related right but he was
like that's the wrong framework
the right framework is it's a war of
attention yes and
spotify is actually competing with
netflix which is competing with twitter
right right and fortnite or yeah and a
game and i mean you can go through it
like literally there's probably
hundreds of platforms and the way to
think about it now i think is i just
look at like how much time do i spend on
my phone yes right
i'm scared look at my computer uh time
spent but on my phone i know i spend
anywhere given the week between four to
five hours a day on my phone
and that's phone calls that's text
message platforms all this stuff
so let's just say that every every
person is pretty good that's that's
that low yeah i think that's low that's
why i don't want to look at my computer
i try to get off my uh
off my phone um but when you look at
that and by the way we should make sure
that we cut this clip and we're going to
send it to polina so that she thinks
that i don't spend that much time on my
phone
but no when you see this so let's say
the average person spends five hours i'm
making this up
if you have an hour podcast you're
asking for 20 of someone's time a day
and maybe that person is a sophisticated
podcast listener so they're gonna put on
two xps now you have 30 minutes right
like that is a huge ask right to get
them to do that
and then if you're doing it two or three
times a week like you know
nearly impossible yes and so i think
that like when you look at all the
platforms
you start to then actually want to
almost prioritize what are the passive
consumption platforms
right like if i can get you to listen to
me in the background while you're at
work
that's a way bigger advantage for me
we're double using that hour
yes then like okay you have to sit down
and read this 20-minute email
yeah exactly like good luck right so the
the best
there's two analogies i've heard about
this one is from the chinese social
networks uh they talked about their
product i think it was the
i think it was the parent company of
tick tock by dance maybe it was
like the wechat company or whatever but
they basically just said
uh somebody had come into a meeting and
they presented
a like a competitor like landscape like
you were talking about like oh
you know they could use us or they could
use you know this other this other
product at the same time
we both do video and they're you know
they're like no this is not the way to
think about it they just mapped out a
customer's day
said okay if person wakes up at 7 00 a.m
what do they
use what technology do they use between
7 and 7 15.
how do we build a product that's going
to fill the while you're brushing your
teeth time
okay then how do we get to the next and
so they just mapped out every hour of
the every waking hour of someone's day
and it sounds like kind of like big evil
tech but
hey look this is what they do they're
making slot machines they're trying to
like get you to keep pulling the lever
is how do we how do we fill up every
hour every you know for every minute of
your day you're waiting in line at
starbucks well what should be a product
that you should use during that time
versus when you're on your commute
versus when you're at work versus
whatever
and then they wanted to build products
along that because they're like this
time is the scarce asset
it's the you know that's the unchanging
thing we all have you know just the same
amount of time in a day
so that that's one thing i heard the
second was from uh
sarah towel from benchmark she said she
put his blog post i was like
imagine a jar and you're gonna fill the
jar and so you have these like big rocks
you put in first and the big rocks are
things like you know like
maybe the time you're spending on email
or facebook or whatever
and then and then you kind of have like
oh well that you know that's a
netflix it's like an hour experience
then you have like
i'm in line and i'm gonna just you know
send a quick text message so then you
fill in kind of like you know the the
smaller pebbles
and you put those in and then you have
the sand and that's like the passive
experience and stuff you could just
it'll fill in all the gaps so if you
want to fill the jar
you got to know which type of product
are you building is it a big rock a
small pebble or is it sand
and then that's that's the way consumer
will sort of like fill up their time
when you think about that from uh the
content platform
you said twitter first uh podcast is
there
another platform or is that just youtube
and that and
you would have skipped the podcast and
gone to youtube so we dabble so i would
go to youtube now but
i think that now that i've worked inside
of these big companies i'm like oh this
is how this works
somebody at the top is like hey tick
tock's big
we need tick tock inside youtube we'll
call it shorts you know
um okay yeah we're going to build it
keeps growing tip top keeps going they
reported a new number oh my god
the analyst says it's eating youtube's
lunch hey guys where's that shorts
product get that shorts product out
there they get it out there
uh okay numbers look okay cool um
put it in the feed put it bigger in the
middle of the feed
every time you scroll three times show
it again and like there's product
managers that are trying to get
shorts views up right or stories oh
snapchat's rising
hey instagram facebook we need stories
put stories in okay cool it's good put
it at the top
you know like send a notification about
it make it blink make it play exactly
put a red flashing thing around it and
so you know like
i think so as a content creator you're
like all right if that's the game
what's your new thing all right i'm
going to make some optimized content for
that well and
and to be clear they're boosting the
distribution early on because they're
trying to tell the creators
you get reach here yeah either they're
they're there's a market it's like
incentivizing pricing right yes
surge pricing and i'm an uber driver and
they're saying if you go over here
you're gonna get double rates
all right i'll go over there and then
that changes and you're like oh [ __ ] the
double rate thing ended i gotta go back
over where i wanted to be anyways
but for a moment in time there's like
this like it's the money ball there
there's an extra point you can get by
using these platforms so
i've been dabbling with that right now
which is what are the things where i
take the same amount of effort or maybe
even sometimes
less effort making some content and get
double or triple exposure
either because the platform's juicing it
or a topic is just like dude every time
i talk about bitcoin it just gets bigger
or like
if i say some conservative thing you
know it goes bigger and like you don't
want to totally sell out but it's
interesting to observe
which of the things you talk about get
much more play than the other thing
you're equally interested in
that just like seems like the market is
not as interested in
do you use that to inform
the content like do you actively sit
down and you're like okay
uh every day i needed to have one tweet
about bitcoin because that's what works
and seems to get the most uh kind of
distribution
or is it more so just something that
kind of give a feel for
and it's less data-driven it's more like
uh it's more
like you observe it you're like okay
there's a truth i accept it
i'm not i don't have to act on it i know
a lot of people
i have good friends that are like dude
twitter threads work i'm gonna do
i'm gonna publish for a week i've
noticed that any more than fours not
optimal
and i'm gonna publish them all at nine
a.m so now i wake up at seven and i do
the thing and i'm like
that's cool but that would suck the fun
out of this for me so
maybe i'm leaving stuff on the table by
not doing that not optimizing it
using all the sort of tools at my
disposal but i need this to be fun
because if it's not fun i'm not going to
keep doing it and i know that like in
the long run the only thing that really
works is if i stick with this for a
certain amount of time
and so i think that's like a pretty
important
like realization which is like most
people burn out doing this
who are the people that don't burn out
they're the people that they talk about
what's interesting to them
they're not trying to just guess what
the audience wants um
and then secondly they do it in a
schedule that like
is is sustainable for them and like it
depends on your level of discipline
you're like a you know you're an army
guy you have discipline i know you wake
up every morning and you write the
newsletter
and that's hard like i could not do what
you do
uh because i'm like a lazy bastard who
like you know just but you're also on
the west coast it's harder
it is harder but like i do i think about
this a lot i do think that uh what ben
thompson is in
uh asia right yeah yeah so like i do
think there's something about
uh either living in the eastern part of
the world moved to greenland or
something yeah
and you basically get a right during the
day and then you your night is the
morning
uh east coast uh or you gotta be on the
east coast i think it'd be
very very difficult to write daily and
publish
morning time west coast and still get
the same results
i don't know why i think that but like
that for some reason feels right
right i had a paid newsletter that was a
daily newsletter
that was um it was it was an interesting
premise it wasn't publishing like
analysis or information i basically had
just said
hey um this is called all access here's
what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna do these three projects i'm
gonna launch a fund
from xero i'm gonna raise some money if
you wanna learn how raising money works
you can follow along i'm going to build
an e-commerce project
if you want to see how you come up with
that how you get to 100 000 in monthly
sales for that i want to show you that
i said i'm not going to teach you
because like i don't know if you i'm not
going to like turn this into content
like i'm not going to turn this into
like a you can do it i'm just gonna show
you how i do it so it's like you're
getting to sit next to me at my desk i'm
just gonna tell you what i did that day
and then if you learn from that or you
think you could do it great and um
that thing got to 50 000 a month of paid
kind of like revenue which is how much
was it a month two
what was it two hundred dollars a month
are these two pretty high prices 150 to
200
a month yeah because it was like you
know you're gonna
learn things that like if you did that
if you implemented them would be high
business value for you
was that was the idea and um and so
i was doing it but i was only able to
last like three months doing it and then
i was like
okay like you know i turned off a 50 000
a month
income stream from this paid newsletter
which my mom and anybody else was like
just sit down and write it it's just
writing that's easy it's free you know
like
you write it mom yeah exactly and she
was like tell me what to say no
but that was you know that wasn't
sustainable
in that situation why not just hire one
person and basically just get on a call
with them for 20 minutes on what you did
that day then they write it
so yeah i could have done that the
problem the main problem with that one
is actually that it wasn't just the
writing
that was like my big mistake uh i was
committing to starting these three
things so i had to like in addition to
my existing set of businesses i
have because they didn't want to hear
about those because like well it's
already working
i wanna i'm at the starting line so show
me at the starting line how you do
things
so i committed to starting three new
things on top of maintaining the [ __ ] i
already do
that was just too much for me uh but if
it was more like
hey what did i do today well you know i
could do that but that content might not
have been
you know worth the the price tag i guess
what's up guys bang bang
i hope you're enjoying this conversation
but before we go any further i want to
quickly tell you about today's sponsor
block five block five's got four
different financial products for crypto
investors
you can deposit crypto and earn up to
eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
deposit crypto and take out a us dollar
loan against your crypto
collateral you can use their
cryptocurrency exchange and have no
trading fees
or you can get a new bitcoin rewards
credit card it's a normal credit card
that when you swipe you get bitcoin back
rather than cash back or airline miles
i'm an investor in the business and a
very happy user
i think you will be too when you go to
blockfy.com
pomp again blockfy.com go check it out
and let me know what you think
all right let's get back into this
conversation i hope you enjoy it so
uh we're starting to get into like
what's called the solo capitalist like
starter pack right you ever seen the
meme of like you know the miami starter
pack or whatever so
what is in the miami start effect by the
way it's uh uh
pretty much everything you could barry's
boot camp membership barry's boot camp
you got to go to car bone
you know eleven shout out to those guys
right
uh you gotta have some sort of like
slides everything real quick
my friend was telling me about this he
goes dude there's like
they're gonna be so happy we're talking
about this on the podcast sponsor me i
i'm i
i want to i've never been but my friend
was telling me he goes he goes dude it's
genius he goes
there's basically a strip club but it's
not seen as a strip club he's like
the guy who started this there's like
geniuses he's like i don't know how they
did it but it's like
it's kind of like a restaurant you go to
and i've never been so tell me where i'm
wrong but he's like it's a restaurant
you go to
and it's kind of got like elements of a
restaurant a strip club and a bar
but it's not he's like the perception is
not like
you're going to a stripper it's not like
a seedy thing is that true is that an
accurate description
from personal experience i've never gone
okay uh i do know
uh one of the guys who owns the place uh
he is an incredible human in terms of
uh very forward-thinking a great
entrepreneur
uh actually started from a real estate
standpoint
um and i think that that's
the big difference is most people
that own strip clubs certain type of
person right like
like if you wake up in the morning
you're like you know i'm sorry you could
show me a picture and i'd be like that's
the kind of guy
right over generalization i'm sure
there's some nice ones too but like you
know
you get the point uh most people who own
uh
clubs also a specific type of person
right right
when you come at it from a business and
entrepreneurship and like hey i'm a real
estate developer
and oh by the way there's happens to be
this big warehouse or this like old club
that was here like
we should do something um i think that
you just come at it from a very
different right like mindset you
you think of it more as a business and
and so you get out of some of the
uh maybe the potholes of like those
other industries and you start to think
about it from
a pure like revenue generation
standpoint and uh i'm serving a customer
and that customer is coming for a
certain type of experience
all this stuff so with all that said uh
yes sorry i direct well i directly know
uh
or i've heard some of the numbers and
stuff like that uh i think it's one of
the highest grossing clubs in the world
that's what i heard yeah and so
uh you just have to one respect like
building anything is hard building in
that kind of cut
throat industry is even harder yeah i
think they last on average two years a
club does and then it like turns over
i've heard uh that the average club
life is shorter than the average nfl
uh player's career right right like
think about that for a second like
we all know that nfl players don't last
that long right so clubs last
year even shorter than that um and so i
think that like
you just have to look at like what is
the mentality of the person who's
starting something like that right and
it's just
pure business right um and so i think
like that's a very unique thing and
that's why it's been so successful
um but going back to uh well there is a
segway which is
okay um there is a we were talking about
the
the solo capitalist sort of starter pack
or solar capitalist playbook
and i think there's uh what we were
talking about before the pod started
rolling and
like most podcasts the best conversation
happens right before and right after
um we were talking about was there an
established playbook
are we kind of in the formation creation
phase and then like
to what extent do you like the people
are having success
are they having success because they
actually came from a unique background
so their point of view was like
i was give i'll give you this example
we'll jump to
this point and then we can go back to
wherever the starting point most people
who were in the like content creation
phase let's say 10 15 years ago take
somebody like tim ferriss
loved tim ferriss loved his books met
him great guy
he wrote books that was like
the playbook you are like you have you
know you have a bunch of knowledge
insight wisdom he started a blog and
like used it basically started blog like
i think
only nine months before his book came
out it was like to promote the book
and like ironically a blog is a much
better business than a book
but like at the time the like the sort
of the buffet of
opportunity to monetize an audience
right not that it's a three-course meal
right and now
it is more like a buffet or you know
it's like a vegas buffet where we have
all these options you could do a
substance paid newsletter you could do
you know like patreon you could do all
these ten
raise a fund whatever like tim ferriss
invested we just invested
i think his own capital and and did well
but like he could have had
you know he did well because he had what
i'll call insider access right he was in
this circle
in silicon valley he was able to get the
best deals right and so you should
invest in uber you know yeah
very good call again right but he was
able to build this
fantastic platform and then ultimately
able to monetize it
but outlier not kind of what everyone of
that era did right
now it's becoming much more uh kind of
simple
and much more understood in order to do
this and so
i guess what i'm seeing now is that
people from different backgrounds are
coming in and that because they came
from such a different background
whether they're an athlete who starts
creating a bunch of content uh right
like
you know pat mcafee show or something
like that or they're you know a business
person
like for most business people to become
go from like
i know for me it felt weird to be like
oh i'm the ceo of a company
we we raised you know 16 million dollars
and we built this
team we have this office hey i'm gonna
go do a podcast like it sounds like
oh wow like you know step down much and
like
but when you go into that you're going
to come in with
this totally different mindset first
like different level of ambition
different like set of skills and
knowledge that like hey why don't we
why don't we raise a fund off this
audience rather than just charging them
for tickets to a
event that we throw or nine dollars for
my book
like so so for example we had a podcast
and we were doing i think
at that time we had made like 75k in ad
revenue over like the nine months or
something
not like nothing to write home about but
it was cool paid for you know some fun
stuff
so if i made 75k of that in that same
time audience didn't change size
but i launched my rolling fun rolling
fund is now a four million dollars a
year
pool of capital for me to deploy into
startups and the only reason it stopped
at four is because there's a cap of how
many investors you can take and we hit
the cap like
right away um you could take only like
99 accredited investors and so
that was for me a very interesting thing
to see
oh man if i just use the traditional
playbook every other podcaster is using
which is
i'd like to read ads out loud then i was
only going to be capped at 75k of total
you know potential value
and then just by bringing in a different
perspective because you know my previous
background of angel investing
i was able to generate 4 million of
annual
uh you know investment commitments that
that was
way better than the ad model right so i
guess that's like an example of like
my version of 11 right coming in from a
different point of view and therefore
getting a very different result
i also think uh most of the musicians
athletes and content creators
of the past take out the outliers but
most of them
were athletes musicians and content
creators
they did not have the business acumen
and so therefore there was a lot of
managers uh business uh
folks they had kind of had to surround
themselves with the right people because
that just wasn't their skill set
and also i don't think they enjoyed it
right i think they really really wanted
to
spend their time on their craft whatever
the thing was they were interested
and business was a second thing i think
what all these platforms have in power
is the exact opposite now
they have business people showing up
being like wait i can have i can have an
audience
right i don't need a business manager i
am the manager right and oh by the way i
have the audience i have this whatever
and so you you start to see some really
really
unique things that are happening where
it's just again uh
almost an outsider to the content
creation world is coming in
but they have the skill set of business
and jamaat there's like a billionaire
with a podcast now right every friday
he's you know you couldn't get a meeting
with this guy but now every friday he's
going to go sit down he's going to
record a podcast he's having fun
but also he's like oh it's good i can
have my own audience i don't have to go
do a cnbc
appearance to get my message out there
right i could just
we have we get a bigger audience than
the cnbc nightly like show would get so
what now i own this we can like they
don't you know run ads on it but for
them it's like
a asset that they they would have you
wouldn't normally have had a billionaire
blogger
right like you know i guess mark cuban
was kind of like an outlier doing that
but
there for the most part that wasn't part
of that wasn't the background of who
came into content creation it was like
more like those who can't do the other
[ __ ] make content and now everybody's in
this game yeah well
and at this point is it uh a necessity
do you have to do it
i don't think you have to do it um you
know we both probably have a bunch of
friends that have
twitter egg profiles and they're like
some of the most successful investors or
whatever
they don't want to play that game but i
think what it did was it created new
paths to win
so it's you know it created you know the
map now has like other
routes you can take to get to the same
end outcomes uh you don't have to have
to be an insider
because you create a an audience now
people come to you you know so
so you get different uh options what
other uh kind of
solo capitalist starter pack items are
you interested in right so you got the
content
i talked to the newsletter talked about
podcasts talked about youtube
what else in that uh are you kind of
spending time thinking about so i think
you go
i think you you start with that secret
sauce what am i interested in then you
create content on one of the many
platforms whichever one works for you if
your voice is annoying to listen to
don't do podcasts right nobody likes
their own voice
i hate my own voice it's a scientific
there's something
about listening to it right yeah there's
i forget exactly what it is there's been
studies
if you hear your own voice you're like
that is a weird voice yeah yeah
i i feel that for sure like do you do
you think morgan freeman thinks that
yeah right he's like can we hire a
professional here
you listen to this that's a great idea
that's a great one
um so you you picked the platform great
now what
uh so i would say like you go through
the options so
i'll i'll give you kind of like what i
see as pretty interesting ways that a
solo capitalist can go from
what used to be like you do it for free
because it's just like
you like creating content as a hobby to
like wow i'm making like
i made i replaced my job income i can
make a hundred thousand dollars doing
this
and then it gets to like i'm a
millionaire right like ben thompson he's
got a paid newsletter he's making a few
million dollars a year
just writing his paid newsletter and now
i think the the size of the prize is
going up
i think you're going to see you know
billionaire content creators
um because they're billionaires and they
go into content
or because they're content contributors
um
and so like i think it's hard i don't i
wouldn't say it's the easiest way to
become a billionaire
in the same way that like you know for
athletes who's the closest do we think
so let's run through some possibilities
okay i think that the people who you
would think like a mr beast
uh who's like you know one of the
largest youtubers and seems to be making
moves here and there
i don't think it's going to be them why
why not why not them
interesting i don't think so because i
think that
um it depends it's not just about size
of audience
and so you have youtube where there's a
different king every
you know sort of like a few years same
thing happens on twitch ninja is the
best
and then tifu is the best and then now
there's like new people who are the best
so there's this like rotation
um that happens as far as like um as far
as that goes
the second thing is who has the ambition
to do it so
um i know that those guys you know
through knight media they're investing
they're doing different things that's
good
but i think they have to have the
playbook and so
i think joe rogan either will get there
or could get there so
single person uh you know sold the
meteorites to the podcast for
reported you know 100 million dollars i
don't know if that's a year or that was
a lump sum
i think they didn't say on purpose yeah
because they want us all guessing
yeah but i would believe that he can get
a hundred million dollars per year
doing that right now he was doing 30
million in ad sales the year before
so right you assume that you know 100
million is probably close
then what else did he do so he created
uh or he's like you know a partner or
co-founder of
on it i don't know what what percent he
owns but
now he's gone into like a supplement
supplements can be a very very big
business right so like you know uh the
rock
releasing protein powder is gonna work
to a degree that like other stuff won't
so
these influencers are realizing why
should i shout out these random brands
for you know cash when i can either
create my own brand
or own equity in i'll demand equity so
lebron did this right
lebron was sponsored by mcdonald's and
he's like hey first of all like
i don't eat mcdonald's so this is like
kind of [ __ ] uh but secondly like
i could invest in blaze pizza it's like
a chain that's growing and like i can
own a significant share of this just by
being lebron like
i want to be on the equity side of the
game rather than being kind of a cash
you know a cash guy and so i think you
have to shift the business model so i
think what we're going to see is
somebody who
creates they get a big enough audience
then
they parlay it through the higher value
possibilities so here's some higher
value possibilities
buying businesses i think there are
plenty of uh like for example
fintech companies that build a product
they build a neo bank they build a
credit card a debit card
and they don't quite make it so they
don't quite get the escape velocity
because they're trying to pay for ads on
facebook to get customers they don't get
all the way there
now what if you're what if you're mr
beast and you decide to
pick up that company so you buy out that
company you own you know you buy 100
essentially
you buy the investors out for 10 cents
on the dollar because they're
they're going under so you take that
same technology but you have the
distribution where you're going to get
an
unfair distribution advantage and you're
going to get a million people using the
debit card
just the way that debit cards work debit
card you're going to be able to take
a one percent fee on transactions so you
get a million people spending a hundred
dollars a month on
on this you're gonna be making tens of
millions of dollars just off that you're
gonna be valued at you know hundreds of
millions of dollars
as of with a fintech product and so i
think people who basically launch
financial products people who buy out
businesses that are already doing good
and take them to the next level using
their fame
or they go into categories like
supplements you know
um chips like
water you know like these like large
consumer plays because if i have a big
loyal audience and they want you know
whatever cbd
whatever these like kind of products are
cbd is a great one because cbd you can't
advertise on facebook and google
so you can't run ads but you can be an
influencer talking about cbd
and so today they all do cash deals but
the ones who launch branded
you know like fully owned products and
take that seriously they're gonna build
a big business in the same way that like
you know whatever 50 cent made more of
his vitamin water you know proceeds than
he ever did as a rapper
and i think you're just going to see
more and more of that so guys who go
into crypto and things like that
so i agree with some of this and i
disagree with someone who's on the
people
okay i'm going to give you a couple of
examples of people who i pretty sure
are built somewhat we know for sharp
billion or some are that are content
creators
kanye west billionaire content creator
right different type of content sure
music
more traditional yeah kardashians i i
don't know how many there were
billionaires at this point but they're
at least two yeah yeah there's being
reports and uh they're like pomp
brothers right like they just keep like
mormon keeps showing up
[Laughter]
uh then somebody that everyone always
forgets about
is howard stern right he reportedly gets
paid almost 100 million dollars a year
uh and he's been doing it now for years
20 years right like
the guy's got to have over a billion
dollars right almost unless literally he
pissed it all away doing like ridiculous
things he's got to have a billion
dollars
uh so those are like three that i think
are uh are pretty simple so
the only caveat so totally agree the
only caveat i would say is
in my lens that i'm thinking through is
uh digital natives so
so somebody who's essentially born and
built they're following so those all get
disqualified because they're more
traditional
yeah so like kanye you know he's got
like a he had like a label and like you
know this is like
he is a content creator but uh i think
when most people think content creator
they don't think professional musician i
think they think more like
youtuber uh or tick-tock okay whatever
so next
is rogan i don't think he ever becomes a
billionaire because i think he's missing
the one thing that
you mentioned which is the ambition to
be the desire yeah
right he's smart and wise enough to
realize it doesn't matter he's got
enough
exactly uh and i think that the spotify
deal uh whether it'll ever be said
publicly or not
was uh kind of a cash out and uh i'm 50
plus years old if he's 53 54 years old
right i want to spend time with my
family
i'm gonna move to austin um i'm out of
the like rat race uh yeah sure you want
to give me a hundred million dollars
like
you know fools right yeah give me a
hundred million dollars by the way i'll
keep producing the content like i enjoy
meeting and talking to my friends
whatever it's cool uh but i definitely
think like that was a
signal of the level of ambition right um
and
that might make him the smartest one out
of everybody like the ability to
say i don't need to go try to be a
billionaire right right uh and then
mr beast i actually think he will be
here i think he has the ambition to do
it
uh but i think that what drives him is
very different right it's kind of like a
uh sam bankman free i don't know how
much you know about him from ftx but
like
jimmy doesn't want to be a billionaire
because he thinks it's going to be cool
to be a billionaire right he's not
looking for a yacht he wants to just
give it all away right he wants to help
people he genuinely enjoys doing that
and so like the passion comes through
and like there's a
financial goal because that will help
empower the passion right right
and so i think that like that's like a
very uh unique
driver of i want to acquire a lot of
financial assets
and then like go along give it away i
don't know how much money he's giving
away but like it's gotta be tens of
millions of dollars at this point
right like pretty incredible for a kid
who's like 25
right like like that's not a thing that
25 year olds think about most people
talk about how much they've made
he's like i've given away more than
you've ever made yeah it's like it's
very very very unique now when you bring
it to
um kind of like people that we don't yet
know of
i actually think most of the blinders it
sounds like you're saying this is like
you built the audience and then you
build a
company yes and so yes you are a content
creator but like really you're an
entrepreneur
yes and i think it brings this whole
conversation full circle of like all
this is is just
they're entrepreneurs right and the
content creators whether you're a
youtuber a twitch streamer
uh you tweet whatever like they're
entrepreneurs the tools have changed a
little bit the
uh mechanisms have changed the
monetization pathways have changed but
really like the soul capital is just an
entrepreneur yeah and when you start to
think about that like
it all makes sense right right and it's
the more things change
the more they say exactly and i would
say the only nuance of like what well
then what is different
it does feel like something's different
but you're totally right that like hey
80 90 percent of it is the same i would
say is there's this
disintegration of the firm um people are
less interested
in firms companies it used to be the
firms had the prestige and now
and you see this in sports i don't know
if you're like a big basketball fan or
whatever but
people used to really really support the
teams you it's like i'm a
i grew up i love the lakers i love the
celtics i love the whatever
and now it's shifted in the nba it's
like i'm a lebron stan
right you know oh my god i love kyrie i
love whatever
and oh lebron switched teams cool i
guess like go lakers
cause lebron's on the lakers now right
and so people
have switched from team loyalty to
individual loyalty it's the same
trend i see everywhere which is this
disintegration of the firm
people don't want to be tied to the one
firm for very long and the fans
also value and want to you know follow
individuals more than the firm you see
this with elon
elon's personal brand now has so much
weight
that elon can just you know he says a
thing market moves
he starts a new company you know the
boring company neurolink whatever
all of a sudden engineers want to go
start working on it investors want to
give them capital that sort of thing
because
elon is bigger than the firm and i think
that that's what i see happening
and with content creators they start
with i am the firm
right and so for better for worse you
know i am the firm and and so i think
that that's the only
difference is like they are the firm and
they're starting with what you said
which is you go customer you go audience
first customer first
business second whereas most things you
build a product in a business and then
you go try to get customers and grow a
customer base
these guys are taking a huge customer's
base and saying great how do i now
build products and companies that are
going to serve these customers so
another corollary to this
that uh people probably haven't explored
enough yet and
and uh probably over time more and more
stories will come out
is uh really it's a brand building
exercise first so everyone talks about
like audience building right because
really it's a brand building because
once you have the brand no brand new
audience
yeah and then like what do oprah
uh you know go down the line there's a
whole bunch of them uh
and i've been looking into like what
have some of these people done they
basically what'd you find built a brand
because of again some secret sauce
whether it was you know oprah with the
talk show and all that by the way what
made oprah great i don't even really
know what
what why is oprah oprah there's um
there's an episode
uh i hope i don't mess this up acquired
uh the podcast
right and they do a whole deep dive on
it
and my main takeaway was like there's
like three or four things right one was
uh who she was in terms of uh her life
experience her willingness to like just
like talk about certain things whatever
two was there was a very specific time
where she kind of rose up
uh she was an african african-american
woman uh
she was not the um kind of body type and
like all these things that everyone like
thought you had to be to be on
television
and they like really go into like the
psyche of
uh there was a person who ran like the
local tv station
or like a certain outlet of a tv network
who decided like oh we're gonna put
oprah on over like some you know old
white guy basically
uh and they talk a lot about like the
dynamics and the pushback that he got
and all stuff but ended up being
obviously jean's decision
and then the third thing probably the
most important thing was she early on
understood like own equity own the
network like buy people out like
like really be the person um
and i've even heard that uh oprah
owns equity or upside or revenue share
of like dr oz right because basically
was like hey
i'm going to like make you famous right
and like you're going to build this
whole business
like i want a piece of that that's
awesome and so like that's like a
very early piece of uh
[Laughter]
i'm not quite oprah but so i i think of
like
that type of person then um i think of
uh
yeah there's a whole bunch of other ones
but like they become
great because of something they build
this brand they take that brand i have a
funny story on that okay
do you know um you know michael buffer
yes the the let's get ready to rumble
guy yeah before every boxing match
do you know what he's worth he's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars because
he licenses to the video games right he
tr
he so actually the funny thing is he
didn't even realize it
his um his brother bruce buffer who is
the guy who does the same thing in the
ufc
um they were half brothers that didn't
know they were brothers
this is great have you heard the story
no bruce buffer
uh he's watching a boxing match and he
sees michael buffer go let's get ready
to rumble
and then he's like oh that's cool his
last name buffer my like i've never met
another buffer
and so he like looked up the phone but
he said are there other buffers couldn't
find one
and he's like driving and he's like
tells his dad he's like yeah dad uh this
that guy michael buffer he grew up
actually like you know three blocks away
from us or whatever like
two miles away from us and his dad's
like yeah i think he might be your half
brother
and he's like what he's like yeah like
before i met your mom i was married
you know like that could be your brother
and so he went he fought they found out
at like age 40 or something like that
they're brothers what bruce at the time
goes to michael and he goes
michael you know what you've done is
amazing you've kind of like carved out
this personal brand you have a monopoly
on this like
you're the guy before every big match
and they're training the audience
before tyson you see this guy and that's
how i get hyped up get your popcorn go
sit down
and he goes you gotta uh like trademark
your stick and said they trademarked
let's get ready to rumble
they started licensing now he's worth
400 million dollars and he also became
sort of like irreplaceable because of
that right and so his
half brother who he didn't know ended up
helping him build that like equity side
and then he started doing in the ufc and
then his
and then michael got him into the ufc
like kind of like you should do
commentary you should do this like i
don't know what to call announcing too
um and got him into the ufc and now he
has his it's like it's
time that's what he says and so before
every ufc fight
he does that and he's made tens of
millions of dollars doing
doing that i mean incredible right like
just
but the idea of like you take this thing
and then you license it right
and it's iep and so ultimately what
that's what i think a lot of these folks
are doing when they're building these
audiences
is they're basically building a brand
and that brand if done correctly
is licensable and all this kind of stuff
so uh i don't know exactly how it plays
out i don't even know if anyone's doing
it well yet but it feels like there's
just this entire generation of people
they did it really well
uh they didn't have the internet and you
know a lot of the stuff and the
playbooks and like all this
the folks today they don't have the
playbooks either but i do think that
like eventually they'll figure it out
and my guess is 10 20 years from now
we're gonna look back and be like oh my
god like that was the playbook like
if you did a b and c and you did it a
then b then c
like you won right and so like it's kind
of cool to see
everyone trying to do different things
do you like
where do you put yourself do you feel
like you have that ambition is that
something you want to do
do you you don't want to follow these
play books what where are you at i want
to be happy
like like that like that is literally i
think about it a lot right of
uh are there's default happy yeah for
sure uh
i'm probably way happier than like most
of my friends right and
uh some of it is probably like there's
freedom elements of like my life
uh but also i think some of it's just
like happiness is like very much a
mindset
right uh i think it's um i think it's
will smith uh he's got this video that
went viral once and he's talking about
his wife
you know or talk about happiness in your
wife is already like
you know be careful will but he
basically is like look
uh i sat down with my wife one time and
i said it is not my job to make you
happy like happiness is like an inside
job i think it's like the line it uses
and it's just like like you're in
control of it it's like no matter what
happens around you like
you can still make yourself happy and
that's
plenty of people disagree whatever but
like that was like full agreement on
my part yeah it's the same right uh and
so like when you see somebody who is
unhappy right you're just like hey man
like you know work on it right
um and so i think that like there's this
element
of if that's what you're driving towards
like
you realize like yeah all the other
stuff is like nonsense right
and uh i don't think i've actually ever
said this but like
one of the things that's like very
unique about uh myself and like my
brothers i think they're very similar
of like if you gave me the option to
like go hang out with a bunch of
billionaires or like
go to dinner with like my brothers and
my wife i'll take my brothers and my
wife like
all the time yeah and like mind you i'm
not perfect like there are definitely
times where i get like an invite
somewhere
and i'll go right so i'm like oh my god
like like you like get into like the
whole thing
and then you're there and you're just
like man like look like like you guys
are nice people whatever but like
no i don't want to go to dinner again
tomorrow night right like like i enjoy a
certain type of lifestyle
and so i think that like that's uh very
unique
because what most people do is they
measure everything from a monetary
standpoint
and like it it's a very fortunate
position when like you're like oh i
don't need to worry about that stuff
right so i
understand that's important but also i
think there's this element
of uh a lot of people are just
doing the next step because they think
that's what they're supposed to do but
they're like what are you optimizing for
right and it gets into this world of uh
the downside of a lot of this right like
you stopped doing the newsletter
because you're like taking away
happiness i can't write every day like
this is this is unsustainable
and so the last thing i want to talk
about uh
if we're going to call people the
solopreneur or the soil capitalist
there's what i'll call
copypreneurs yes which is okay i just
saw sean do something that looks awesome
i'm gonna do it as well
now what's the saying uh
great artist steele yes writer whatever
that saying is uh so it's not that like
oh don't copy anybody else like do
everything yourself
but there's definitely people out there
who just like okay i saw this person do
it now i do it next then i do it next i
do it next
and what i always wonder is like how
long can they do that because like
there's no passion
uh they have no like kind of
understanding of how this all fits
together it doesn't feel very authentic
and it almost feels like they're just
gonna run off a cliff and then do it all
over again run off another clip and then
again and again and so like i don't even
know if there's a solution it just feels
like that's a thing that happens and
like those people just have to learn
over time by like running off the cliff
a couple times
yeah i think that well the hard part is
it kind of works
and kind of works is like an addictive
thing right it's like something like a
job being kind of good
and it's like well you're gonna probably
stay there if it really sucked you'd
leave
it was really amazing you wouldn't even
you know it's like not bad not right
like right
not bad it's a not bad job not bad is
the worst right so because not bad will
keep you stuck in it for a very long
time
raising your most valuable asset so the
same thing happens for
the copypreneur right the copypreneur
does the thing
and gets half the result and they you
know they're always sort of wondering
like how come it just doesn't work
better for me well it's like
because there's like that diagram of an
iceberg
and it's like you know what you see
that's like what went into it
and it's like they just they can only
copy you to what you see they only copy
what it is
if they don't have the understanding of
why this worked why this worked in this
context
what might come next that sort of thing
and so uh you know you see this all the
time you see this with like
what's happening with nfts it was like
this rush oh this guy made this image
and sold for this much i'm gonna make an
image and sell for this much but like
the as the copiers came in everybody
started to lose more and more and more
and it was only somebody who's doing
something unique and novel who said
oh that's cool i'm going to do something
like that
it might be even 80 like that but the 20
i change is gonna make all the
difference in the result that i get
and so that's kind of the way i see it
is like i'm constantly
stealing ideas looking for inspiration
saying oh that's really cool
you know props rarely do i ever just
wholesale and say oh yeah i'm gonna do
the same thing it's always like
let me look at that did it work why did
it work
and then how could i put my spin on it
how can i make it
better for me uh how can i take it to
the next level because we're all kind of
creatives
we're not competing against each other
we're sort of building this stack this
cascade where
you did a thing then i did a cool
different thing and then you did a thing
and together
we built this tower of cool [ __ ] on the
internet and so that's
that's the way i sort of see that the
copypreneur
doesn't quite go all the way there and
you know you want to be
you want to be taken 80 and innovating
you're 20.
what is the best piece of advice you
have for people
who want to get started and then what's
your greatest
warning for people who want to get
started so
i'll give you kind of uh this is
actually perfect copyprinter thing i
hope i don't throw this guy under the
bus too much so i had this guy who kind
of became my like
apprentice quote unquote sort of like
hey i need some help you know
with this content thing is taking off i
need some more horsepower um
come in and help me with that and then
i'll sort of like show you how i do what
i do and then
you want to do that someday so you'll
learn about it he's a college student
and so um what i said was like great
like i'm in this niche of like
i'm a business person entrepreneur so i
kind of write about that stuff
and um and i write about things that i
know
or i've experienced or i've like learned
the hard way so if i'm giving somebody
advice
because i like did the thing um and then
there's other times where i'm a total
novice in something i say hey
i'm a noob i'm trying to learn this and
if you're a noob trying to learn it too
like i'll just share what i'm learning
as i go i think that totally works as
well
and um so the guy who came in he was
helping me out he's great
and his audience his twitter audience at
the time i think was like one or two
thousand followers
and in just a few months it's now 40 000
followers and how did he get there he
started writing twitter threads he
started writing the same threads that me
and like five other people were doing
to try to grow our audience and it works
he's doing the copypreneur thing
and i sent him a message because he
would like say he would send me the
thread be like hey can you share this
i'm like dude i would love to share your
stuff but like
i feel like you're just regurgitating
the same thing
and also like that's not your that's not
your experiences really
like um if he if what he was doing was
like so what would i think would be a
better path so the advice i
i gave him or would give anybody else is
instead of looking at the people who
have are doing something successful and
just copying it like he was looking at
people who
had you know investors or business
people 10 15 years older than him
that had done certain things and he was
just trying to like kind of like distill
those and repackage them
and and put them out as life advice i
said your best your best content is when
you talk about the fact that you're a
college senior figuring stuff out
because that's what you do and you know
that we don't know if i wrote something
from the
about what's going on in college how
kids are thinking what you know how
you're navigating this thing
i would never be able to write that
content so you're today you're competing
you know you're bringing sort of a spoon
to a knife fight here
and instead like what you should be
doing is you should be
owning your niche of like the thing you
are which is
21 years old hungry you're learning
everything from you know all these
places and you're you're trying to make
it and you know the new world better
than
us old guys do and so that'd be my kind
of my my advice is like
do interesting things do do unique
things first don't try to build an
audience first
share the unique and interesting things
you're doing so just like work in public
and that'll automatically build you an
audience passively as you go
and don't just like don't look at what's
already worked
and just like like identify the 80 that
you want to copy but
make sure you're really clear on the 20
that's you that you're bringing into
this otherwise
long run it's not going to work you
might build followers but you will never
build
affinity you'll never build love and you
can't do the successful playbook
if you don't have that trust and love
from your audience and that's only going
to come if you actually are bringing
something unique to the table and
it's authentic to you
i think there's this element of
authenticity
that the internet is the greatest like
[ __ ]
filter and if you're not being authentic
eventually it does chew you up and spit
you out and you're like
this wasn't real right uh if you're
authentic it's the greatest moat
possible on the internet right
and authentic for each person is
literally different
right and so like maybe you're the smart
nerdy you know super technical person
and then maybe you're a [ __ ] poster
right like
and by the way neither one of those are
good or bad yeah like who's the one kid
uh uh
uh what is his twitter handle uh trung
trunk uh
like chung's amazing he's smart but he's
a [ __ ] poster yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
and by the way if he had a shirt where
he could wear a badge that said like i'm
a [ __ ] poster he would wear it and be
like
super proud and like that is what makes
it so unique
and guess what now he's on cnbc because
he's everyone's favorite [ __ ] poster yes
and like that's what i think the beauty
of the internet provides right
is that like you can literally do
whatever you want
and there is an audience to find you if
you're good at it yeah and
what's that phrase about the stock
market where it's like you know in the
short term it's a popularity contest in
the long term it's like a weighing
machine or whatever
i think there's the same thing for the
internet which is like in the short term
it's more of a reaction contest who said
the most reactionary thing
and in the long term it's an
authenticity contest and like
i hate the word authenticity because
like a [ __ ] word gets overused
so like whatever we need to find another
word
but it that really is what that really
is what matters on that front so
you know if you're trying to do the the
kind of solo capital solo media playbook
i would say like
to me there's you know i kind of share
my thoughts on
what order to go in but also like don't
get that one thing wrong
uh like don't chase what you think will
work be like
what's really me and then how do i push
me from like the inside out i want to
put me out to the world
because what that does is it attracts
other people who genuinely like you
that you will your audience will find
you the audience might start small
doesn't matter
it might like you know end up medium
size like there's a bunch of things i
could do
to try to get a bigger audience but it
wouldn't really be what i care about or
what i'm interested in what i'm good at
so long term that's not a good move for
me you know so i would say like
the goal is to take what take you and
put it on blast
and not like uh you know just sort of
copy other people or fake the funk
three questions to end you could ask me
one at the end uh
first is what's the most important book
you've ever read
i read this book called story worthy and
um
it's a book that i don't know if it's
the most important the most important
one the last few years
story worthy is a book on telling
stories it's this guy who's a third i
think he's like a third grade teacher a
fifth grade teacher
matthew dix and he uh he goes to these
little storytelling
events uh like it's like a rap like a
rap battle but it's a story battle and
he's like won it 20 times or something
like that
and he's just a master at telling
personal stories
and i think that that is one of the most
valuable tools at your disposal
that they don't teach you in school and
so when i read it i was like
oh i get why the people i like i like i
get why the movies that work
work and he just breaks it down so
simply
these little these little things he's
like watch uh if the beginning of the
movie
is if the beginning of the movie is a
a high-powered lawyer who she's fiercely
independent she doesn't need no man
and you know um she's you know super
successful in her professional career
watch by the end she's going to be in a
loving relationship and she's going to
be a baker doing what she loves
right like it's like the is a story is
basically
a change it's like a personal is a
change and the best way to like start a
story
is to take the change that happened in
the end and just find the opposite and
so he talks about how to write a story
but then he then when you
you can't go back and watch you know he
does a great one on jurassic park
you go watch jurassic park and like you
can't unsee
the underlying storytelling mechanics
that are in it and
once you know those it makes you a more
interesting person uh when you do what
you do so i would say story worthy is
probably like
the most impactful book i read last few
years all right i haven't read that i'm
gonna have to go read that now that was
pretty good description uh second
question
is sleep schedule uh our friends over at
eight sleep
have me sleeping on this thermoregulated
bed now yeah um
i liked it so much that i literally
begged them to invest in the company
right it's like the best like that's
like basically the answer yes uh i seem
super cold
like eight nine hours now uh and now
don't go all the way to ten but i
definitely go like pretty cool like five
or six
okay um what is your sleep schedule now
and like how has that evolved over the
years
uh well so i have two little babies so
my sleep schedule
is and my wife does most of the like the
night stuff so i get off easy but
um it doesn't matter what time i sleep
the kid's still waking up
at 7 00 am or 6 30 in the morning and
that's my
that's daddy time so like i wake up now
i used to be uh like sleep in until nine
i used to sleep until 10
roll into the office at 10 30. like
that's kind of how i used to go and now
it's like i'm up at 6 30 or 7 every day
um but i don't sleep on
i try not to be super scheduled so i'll
sleep at i would say on average midnight
but like last night three in the morning
you know like that doesn't matter where
the bitcoin conference you know
well exactly i was doing i wasn't doing
cool [ __ ] i wasn't at a party
i was just on the internet being like
this is awesome the internet is
every night i'm like that was midnight
west coast time yeah right so yeah
that makes sense all right uh last
question aliens leader or non-believer
well i feel like the news broke i feel
like they found some aliens or something
i don't know what's going on
i i think that no i don't believe uh
that there are aliens i think that
it's more likely uh i think the
simulation stuff is more likely than
aliens so i i i
have more on that front so the reason i
actually did this last time yeah and uh
i want to see if your interchange
i think it pushed ufo uh i think it
might have because
uh i actually do like go down these
rabbit holes again the internet is
awesome
i go down these rabbit holes and i'll
change my perspective based on like you
know
basically fake videos on youtube is as
best i can describe them
uh everything we're fed is fake the
videos are fake the news is fake
literally people's opinion is fake like
the internet has
uh completely exposed just like this
narrative driven world
is like so hard to figure out what's
real right well like you know if you
just go try to find like what should i
eat what's good nutrition
you'll see that like some people say eat
only meat and some people say meat gives
you cancer and like you're going to die
if you eat red meat and so like
well which one is it guys like i need to
like shouldn't shouldn't we have come to
some kind of concern
you've got a little bit of meat right
you know some other like vegetables
that's the worst never do moderation
right like just only go to these
extremes and that will work
all right what a question you have for
me to finish up uh
okay let's go you talked about happiness
and um
i did this exercise once i wanted to
hear your answer i did an exercise where
i was like
what is uh what is an amazing
tuesday a normal tuesday so i basically
said
my happiness is not going to be from
these extreme events it's going to be
from my normal day
normal day is awesome i win yep so
what's like a normal day that i think
would be awesome and i sort of wrote
down i was like
for example uh just to help you kind of
understand what this weird question
means
is like i love to shower showering is
like
i have a i have a blast in the shower
and i'm just like
i feel great a shower is like a massage
it's like you know
a shower is just like an incredible
thing i get my best ideas
i'm listening to music or i listen to
podcasts like nobody bothers me
you listen to podcasts in the shower
yeah somebody came up to me last night
and literally said hey man this is kind
of weird but like i listen to podcasts
in the shower and i was like that's not
that weird i guess he goes no but i
wanted to preface that when i tell you i
listen to you in the shower
right i listened to you and dan held in
the shower this morning so
so yeah i do that for example i was like
man every
my great day i want to have a shower
every day i love showering and so i had
like four or five things
i'm just like you were talking about
hanging out with your brothers or
whatever uh so i want to know what's a
what's a what's a perfect
perfectly average tuesday for you
i grew up in a really big family and and
i've thought about this a little bit
more
lately so i've got four brothers five of
us total uh
and my parents basically had this like
mentality with us of like
you guys are all boys you're going to be
absolute
animals with each other in the house
like let's prevent or
mitigate collateral damage no playing
sports in the house like all like the
the normal family rules but we also know
that we have five boys and like you guys
gonna be crazy so like
go outside and do it or like go in this
one room and do it right
and so like naturally we like didn't
have tons and tons of friends growing up
because like we just had each other all
the time right so it wasn't like uh
people weren't like coming to our house
or like all this stuff like it's just
like no i have my brother's shirt that's
built in uh yeah and then like you know
we went outside or whatever uh and so i
think that like that dynamic
for like my entire life uh we just like
replicate it now
so like the perfect day is literally
like
my brothers and i all meet up right like
some of them have girlfriends some of
them have wives whatever and like we all
just like
hang out and hanging out has become like
very
weird as we've gotten older because it
still involves the same
verbal activities but uh
the physical activities have changed and
what i mean by that is like we just
talk [ __ ] to each other all day long and
it's not like malicious stuff right but
it's just like hey man like fix your
hair right like
you know like or like hey dude uh you
know uh
i don't know um i saw that you tripped
as you were walking in like that would
be like the really like simple stuff
and then some of it's like you know we
know each other's like insecurities and
stuff and i can really hammer on each
other
but it's all in good fun and like we
joke all the time that like
for whatever reason like when you're in
that environment the level of trust is
so
high that the brutalness and the honesty
comes out and it's fun like we just
genuinely
enjoy doing it and so i think like
that's it it's less about like the
activity you're doing
and it's more about like the people that
you're with and when you then like put
that into like
application it's just like it doesn't
matter what we do like we could
literally go
like i don't know go to the beach we
could you know come here to the office
or like whatever
but like when we're all together i think
we just like laugh right and when you're
laughing and like you're happy
doesn't really matter what you're doing
it's just the people right hard to be uh
upset and laugh at the same time
yeah like yeah and if you are like
you're probably like a psychopath
[Laughter]
all right where can we send people to
find you on the internet and then uh
let's plug the podcast where should they
go download that yeah so uh podcasts go
to
my first million is the name of the
podcast so uh we hit
top 10 this week which is great so my
first million it's a business podcast
where we just shoot the [ __ ] about
business ideas
and then if you want to find me get my
newsletter and all that good stuff it's
all free
uh just seanpuri.com so
s-h-a-a-n-p-u-r-i dot-com
awesome thank you so much for doing this
we're gonna do it in the future yeah
enjoy miami